[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
cette ut loisirs merci de nous retrouver
pour votre numéro dédié à vos idées
sorties tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 11 mai animations rencontres de
professionnels et exposition c'est la
27e édition de mes desserts ce week end
à maurepas
un événement pour sensibiliser petits et
grands à la biodiversité
nous en parlerons avec votre invité
michel aubert responsable de ce rendez
vous incontournable pour la ville c'est
une première depuis son édification en
1788 la maison de la reine poufre ses
portes au public ce samedi 12 mai située
dans le hameau de marie antoinette au
château de versailles elle a été
entièrement rénové l'occasion de
redécouvrir son petit château aux
allures de village normand pour notre
rendez-vous juniors nous irons dans une
galaxie pas si lointaine à versailles
une boutique dédiée à la saga star wars
vous accueillent des rencontres avec des
acteurs sont prévus un lieu qui invite
les fans comme les curieux et depuis fin
mars une graine au tec a ouvert à
guyancourt dans la médiathèque jean
rousselot sur le même principe qu'un
prêt de livres ou de céder les
participants peuvent emprunter des
graines pour faire pousser des fruits et
des légumes chez eux
seule condition échanges et d'autres
graines et régulièrement des ateliers
semis sont proposées par les
associations partenaires pour recueillir
des conseils
quelques précisions au micro de nicolas
kirillovitch il ya plein de choses
pédagogique à l'autonomie alimentaire le
fait de de prendre le temps aussi de
voir les choses poussées et puis
expliquer aux gens effectivement que que
la nature a toujours fonctionné comme ça
qu'a effectivement à partir du moment où
on empêche les graines de repousser
d'une année sur l'autre ont confisqué
une logique qui a fonctionné pendant des
millions d'années est à noter que le
prochain atelier aura lieu le 2 juin ce
sera au tour du zéro déchet ce week-end
c'est la deuxième édition de la fête des
abeilles aux fermes de gally animations
conférences jeux et goûter les visiteurs
sont attendus pour découvrir cet insecte
indispensable à notre alimentation
samedi 12 mai deux visites avec un
apiculteur sont proposés pour aller voir
de plus près à quoi ressemble une rue
l'an dernier les fermes de gally en
planter 7 hectares de plantes mellifères
pour nourrir les abeilles
elle invite le grand public à en faire
de même chez soi on va aider les gens à
semer eux mêmes ou à planter eux mêmes
des plantes mellifères dans leur jardin
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que lors de ces
deux journées du 12 et du 13 mai
prochain nous allons mener plein
d'action notamment un jeu destination
des enfants et des adultes et tous les
gens qui participeront tous les enfants
tous les adultes qui participeront à ce
jeu repartiront avec des sachets de
graines de plantes mellifères qu'ils
pourront eux-mêmes peloter sur leur
balcon sur leur terrasse dans leurs
jardins amateurs de jardinage et
amoureux de l'environnement vous avez
rendez vous tout le week end à maurepas
27e édition de mes desserts événement
consacré à la biodiversité
michel aubert responsable du service
espaces verts de la ville est avec nous
pour nous parler des animations bonjour
bonjour alors le mot d'ordre de ce
week-end c'est le jardinage aussi
beaucoup des rencontres avec des
professionnels sont prévues des conseils
et même des ateliers où on anime un
atelier bouturage on tombe on explique
aux personnes comment faire des boutures
en part elle donc cette année c'est le
centenaire du de la fin de la première
guerre mondiale
donc en fait on distribue aux enfants
des à chaque enfant un sachet de bleuets
parce qu'en fait le bleu est elle le nom
qu'on donnait aux soldats donc quand il
arrivait parce qu'il avait une tenue
un uniforme bleu et tout immaculée du
coup et tout particulier voilà donc
et donc c'était pour ça et c'est pour ça
que ça c'est resté après deux nouvelles
recrues pour tout ce qu'on fait l'armée
on les appelait les bleus ensuite on a
deux différents exposants entre autres
on a un apiculteur qui va donner des
conseils pour le disait monsieur tout à
l'heure pour planter des plantes
mellifères
on a une conférence le samedi sur les
abeilles
l'aca à 15 heures confie une autre
conférence sur les chenilles
processionnaires ont ensuite le
le samedi après midi et le dimanche
après midi on a des promenades en poney
à d'autres taux n'est gratuit pour les
enfants
j'allais venir justement donc il ya les
conférences à ça reste plutôt aux
adultes mais aussi beaucoup d'animations
pour les enfants mais dessert c'est
aussi un événement qui se veut vraiment
très familiale wii de vendredi donc
aujourd'hui on avait on a 2 650 enfants
qui sont passés auxerre on leur faisait
une visite où il voyait la lpo qui leur
expliquait la raison
comme quoi c'était utile de garder les
oiseaux on leur faisait du rempotage
tout le week-end les enfants peuvent
faire du rempotage également ensuite on
a
[Musique]
en distribuant distribuer du compost au
gratuitement à toutes les personnes qui
vont venir ainsi que des bulls et des
bulles qu'on plante est sur nos massifs
plutôt que de les jeter en l'hérault
donne aux personnes
on leur donne des conseils tous les week
end via des jardiniers qui seront sur
place pour expliquer l'intérêt de trade
and day trop zéro phyto est sûre moore
pas nous sommes hors au zéro phyto donc
ce qui permet de conserver une bonne 10e
bonne du bir bonne biodiversité
attention effectivement à
l'environnement c'est ça aussi un
objectif de mes desserts justement ce
que vous avez cités on en parlait avec
les abeilles qui sont à l'honneur
également à maurepas et on peut
découvrir vous l'avez cité la lp o donc
la ligue protectrice des oiseaux
globalement sans rendez-vous qui vise
vraiment à sensibiliser le public à
l'environnement
tout à fait tout à fait c'est la base de
notre dos journée et à côté de ça donc
on anime différentes choses
on va ensuite rond explique aux gens ce
qu'on fait sur la ville est cette année
particulièrement puisque on a et on a eu
de fleur au concours des villes fleuries
d'ailleurs c'était assez exceptionnel
d'après ce qu'il nous avait dit puisque
nous ont donné de fleurs d'un coup on
n'a pas parlé peut-être des nouveaux
exposants si vous avez parlé d un peu
con pouvoir 3 mai pour cette 27e édition
des nouvelles nouveaux venus oui on a
fait un stand pour faire l'initiation à
la vannerie avec la vannerie par exemple
ce qu'il ya vannerie en fait c'est pour
faire des paniers avec de l'osier
donc on aura un espoir une personne qui
sera là pour tout et les gens qui
voudront s initier à la vannerie
ensuite on a une
une autre un stand avec comme quoi pour
le commerce équitable c'est important
d'acheter certaines choses on
sensibilise aussi les enfants on leur
donne un petit fascicule sous forme de
jeu comme quoi faut manger pour qu'ils
puissent manger bio c'est important
pareil ça ensuite on parle beaucoup
aussi des méthodes alternatives aux
engrais et aux pesticides et aux engrais
comme quoi on n'est pas obligé de mettre
de l'engrais ou des pesticides on peut
mettre des paillages ou des choses comme
ça comme quoi on peut aussi plutôt que
de traiter les pucerons
on peut de mettre des coccinelles pour
manger les pucerons donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle la protection biologique
intégrée donc toujours dans cet esprit
de sensibiliser le public
toujours dans cet esprit merci beaucoup
en tout cas michel aubert d'être venu
sur notre plateau donc mes desserts
n'oubliez pas c'est ce samedi 12 et
dimanche 13 mai aux serres municipales
de mots report n'a pas précisé mais
l'entrée est gratuite et tous les
renseignements sont sur le site internet
de la ville merci beaucoup michel aubert
on me refuse c'est une première au
château de versailles ce week-end les
visiteurs pourront admirer la maison de
la reine avec un guide elle ouvre ses
portes au public pour la première fois
depuis son édification en 1788
mélanie poquet et marion ptac l'ont
visitée si louis saez vivait dans son
château
la reine elle avait son hameau il y a
une semaine versailles fait à la fin des
rénovations de la demeure de
marie-antoinette trois ans de travaux
pour reproduire au mieux l'atmosphère de
la maison de la reine ça imite un
village normand
mais en réalité vous avez des salon
salle à manger salle de billard de
boudoir un appartement entier pour la
reine une laiterie préparation une
laiterie de propreté bien évidemment les
bâtiments de service le réchauffement
quel nom donner à la cuisine c'est à
dire un vrai château toutes les pièces
et extérieur de la maison ont été
rénovés grâce aux documentation
historique le hameau de la reine se
situe dans un écrin de verdure au pied
d'un lac
c'est dans ce cadre bucolique qu'elle
souhaitait éduquer le successeur de
louis saez le hameau est à la fois
retirez de l'étiquette et du protocole
c'est aussi un lieu où elle est elle
même où elle dit qu'elle vit en
particulière où elle n'a pas
effectivement les contraintes de la cour
à travers les années la charpente s'est
dégradée et napoléon a même transformer
l'édifice pour l'impératrice
marie-louise après la révolution
c'est l'architecte patrice bonnet qui
s'est en partie atteler aux rénovations
pour reproduire la maison de la reine de
l'époque ne va pas faire une
restauration seulement conservatoire ou
restauratrice il va exprimer que ce
hameau était à la fois un bâtiment de
marie antoinette et un bâtiment pour
l'impératrice marie-louise le hameau de
la reine ouvre ses portes au public à
partir du 12 mai comptait 22 euros pour
visiter les jardins et les appartements
[Musique]
à la musique de star wars
elle nous vient d'une galaxie lointaine
très lointaine vous l'avez forcément
reconnus si vous êtes fans une boutique
entièrement dédiée à cet univers vient
d'ouvrir à versailles
cai lorraine a pris la place de notre
chroniqueuse bon local mis à jour vers
c'est la galaxie pour venir de relance
et une loi et non ce n'est pas qu'elle
aurait évidemment c'est aurélie ronge
cette semaine qui a quand même pris la
place de mélanie qui va nous faire le
rendez-vous des juniors et vous n'êtes
pas venu les mains vides alors on peut
trouver justement ce genre d'accessoire
à côté de vous à personne tout à fait
puisque la moire larmor geek star wars a
ouvert ses portes il ya tout juste une
semaine rue de satory ou là je regarde
mon brushing la séparation peut-être le
nom de l'armorique vous dit quelque
chose c'est normal puisqu'il existe déjà
une boutique armoires geek à versailles
consacré à l'univers harry potter on
avait déjà paris est donc cette fois
c'est sûr la saga spatiale aux neuf
films à qui s'adresse cette boutique
alors c'est un fan shop un comprenez
boutique de fans alors bien sûr c'est
pour les enfants et les ados qui ont
découvert star wars avec les derniers
épisodes 7 et 8 également lé spin off
comme gwan
mais cela s'adresse aussi aux grands
enfants qui suivent la saga depuis 1978
alors l'avantagent camille avec ce type
de boutique et bien cela évite de payer
des frais de port puisque général
eh bien on doit commander ses produits
sur internet ça vient de l'étranger et
bien sûr la facture peut très vite
s'alourdir alors qu'elle produit peut-on
prouver alors on peut trouver des
masques comme vous venez le voir on peut
trouver également des sabres laser il ya
également des vêtements des figurines
des jeux des mugs il y en a évidemment
pour tous les prix le petit plus c'est
bien c'est qu'on peut trouver des
produits exclusifs regardez vous allez
avoir ici un t-shirt exclusif par
rapport à l'inrs et par rapport à en
solo donc chewbacca rétro années 4 70 80
et je vais vous faire voir une petit un
petit produit exclusif
la mallette métallique de honsel s est
même plus qu'une boutique car de
nombreux événements sont organisés en
effet des surprises vous attendent
notamment le 15 mai à l'occasion de la
sortie à cannes de solostar warstory et
pour être au courant et bien des
prochains événements vous pouvez vous
rendre sur leur site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran et bien
sûr que la force soit avec vous aurélie
nul doute que vous trouverez pourquoi
compléter votre panoplie heures de
cadence est évidemment complet remonter
dans votre vaisseau quant à nous on
passe à notre agenda
du théâtre de la danse et de la musique
le festival des talents clés siens
revient pour une nouvelle édition aux
clayes-sous-bois du 3 au 26 juin
l'événement met à l'honneur les talents
de la ville la soirée d'ouverture a lieu
vendredi 18 mai à 19 heures rendez vous
à l'espace philippe noiret pour un
spectacle des quatre muse de 7,8 loisirs
est maintenant terminé merci de nous
avoir suivis je vous retrouve henry
prochain pour un nouveau numéro et je
vous souhaite un excellent week end
m
où